plumes of smoke and blazing fire at an
oil depot in vasel cave about 40
kilometers south west of kiev
ukrainian media say the fire is the
result of a russian airstrike the
ukrainian capital itself has spent
another night under heavy artillery
bombardment
as the russian push to reach the city
intensifies
satellite imagery shows a 60 kilometer
column of russian tanks breaking away in
different directions in an attempt to
encircle the capital kiev is already
besieged from the north the east and the
west
now the russian army is trying to
complete the circle from the south
it is believed ground troops are 25
kilometers away from the heart of the
capital
on the morning of march 12 high
precision long-range weapons attacked
ukraine's military infrastructure
including the military airfield in vasil
kov and the main center of radio and
electronic intelligence of the ukrainian
armed forces in bravery in total during
the operation
3491 objects of the military
infrastructure of ukraine were disabled
the impact is visible across ukraine
including here in the eastern town of
volno
look we were sitting in basements and
they were walking around everywhere
shooting we couldn't leave the basement
for over a day then i walked up to a
soldier and i said boys my mum is
bedridden up there she's a grandma and i
can't go up there the guys wanted to
help me bring her down into the basement
but when we went up there she had
already died it was already too late
residential areas in kiev and mario paul
lie in ruins
the russian onslaught has also
intensified in northern eastern and
southern ukraine
bringing more death and destruction to
populated cities
ukraine has accused russian forces of
having kidnapped the mayor of melitopol
in the southeast of the country
protesters gathered in front of the
city's local government headquarters
demanding the release of the mayor
we demand the mayor be immediately
released we're talking to france germany
israel and others i personally have
called german chancellor schultz and
french president macron i'll talk to
everybody necessary in order to get our
people released we expect world leaders
to show how they can influence the
situation and do one simple thing get
this one person released the very person
that represents the people of militarpol
there have been several attempts at a
ceasefire while the human exodus within
and out of ukraine continues
today march 12 2022 we announced the
opening of the next humanitarian
corridors i very much hope that it will
be a good day all the planned routes
will be open and russia will abide by
its commitments to ceasefire guarantees
i will inform during the day about the
results of our humanitarian routes
these videos published by the head of
the zoporizia regional state
administration alexander starok on his
official telegram channel seemed to show
the progress of a column of buses and
red cross vehicles on their way to mario
paul from zapporusia on saturday
at least one million ukrainians have
been internally displaced by the war
while more than 2.5 million have been
forced to leave the country
muhammad al-jazeera